me
おはようございます
わー
虎担当の枝ですよろしくお願いしまーす
やあああ
トナカイ担当中野ですよろしくお願いします
yeah
ちばうま担当棚沢ですよろしくお願いします
うわあああああ
バルタン10日町ですいやです
宜しくお願いしますあああああ
ある意味だぞまず os あじゃあんロリ
よろしゅう
[拍手]
フェスタんどう佐藤んよ柱状図
ni
まーすきりんタンと聞いたりですよろしくお願いします
萬栄
もうかなりどこ忙しいんですよろしくお願いします
よろしゅう
今回の動物サーバーバトルの好きは私
虎が染めさせていただくやっ
よろしくお願いしまーす
いやー
私たちがやるべきことは
どんな場所に落とされても
必ず
外場所から
落ちないことだ
俺たちの仲間で
シッターに落ちたやつデー
[音楽]
助かった者はいない
うぉっ
k
俺たちがなくかして
何よりも
ある人は
動物さは場所のプレーしている
子どもたちだということを肝に銘じておけ
オギャー
いやだあああっ
2わー
生んだよの先生いつも俺のほうばるし合ってよ
宿題ちゃんと出してるんじゃねーかよもう
まあ
ています
抱くだーうわーーー誰とこいつをどうぞ
タブーああ
[音楽]
ふーん
うーん同母スターバトルでもやったーーー
所ナチュラーん
シャルカー
今日たツアーシャアいくぜ
これ誰だからなああああ
[音楽]
ほんと入るさまだ問題
ああああああ
rar
[拍手]
ねぇいいねぇ
こ
[音楽]
だって俺生きてるぞ
もうしまう1アッシマーしまいラッシュアワー
[拍手]
rar
200者
[音楽]
はあああああっ
ブーブー jr
coo デー jr しゃー
ブーブー
ああああああああ
ran
あああああ
re
car
あああぁああ
maroo
ロラって
none
あああん
草まだ行けたなぁともう1回やろう
えっもう一度名始まるぞこわー
食ザー次は負けられねぇかんな本当にクズえしゅピンを左に
とええええええええええ
rar
[拍手]
やれやれ
ran
これ
[音楽]
毎日つけすげー
[拍手]
30おっこんなああああ
nara
感じ
me
いやぁああああああ
考える
どーん girl ぞこれ
戦前を止めた俺じゃな方ではなかったっけ
can do do ん
かれん
[音楽]
me
グッズかだ母
キルんか archi んだ知事や塀を沸かしてくださいよもう
わー
アーロ
あっはにーを企画頑張ってやばくねなんかええっこんなことあるよイェーイ
よだそれじゃ俺だけ
超でスロー
4キャラだああ
me
ni
それが虎どうしようと所はぁ
ジャム笑いのキーボード側に難しいんだぞ
部署おかあさーん
rego 究極のプレイ
ああああああ
は2
ni
ああああああああ
恋なんだよ
わー店にとっとろジャックだと思いは
ローマンせる合わせてないだろう
彼らの中でいいんだよ御山町な始まるぞ
は皆
3回生は
3なる力をじゃなあああ
ああああああ
次はお通夜あるべくモールの限界まで動物たちを積み重ねてやろっと
よしがんばろ the
あああああ
[拍手]
を急いでわぁああああああ
はあああああ
グリーン
can
[音楽]
4 r はいってやつ
いやー今日開封中
こ
う7
ああああああ
産休を取った
これウスっ
[音楽]
ああああああ
ポスター俺だうぇいさーん kea
[音楽]
うん
はい俺が貼ってくださいそれじゃああー
かっこええ
[音楽]
うんこれ
ん
ます持ってるよああいやああああっっっ
小平
ああああああ
えっ
hey
[音楽]
[拍手]
rar
はい
[拍手]
じゃあ行くぞや year
ああああああ
ああああああああ
me
ブービー ear
わーい reo カールもうデー
ああああああ
ああああああああああああん
ぶーだよわぁ
ああ
[音楽]
はいてあげていかなかったでしょうかの動物とあー戻るの動物たちがもし仕事っぽかっ
たらどんな感じなんだと思ってやってみました
いかがだったでしょうか
結構大変でした今回なんでまで動物サマーカットの実写させたかと言いますと
m スポという勝ち抜けのバトル機能が追加されたみたいでございますそれどんなもの
かといいますと
全国のプレイヤーと商品2つのボディショ
商品をかけてバトルすることができますガチで
で勝ち抜けバトルに勝利すると何がもらえるかといいますと
商品として m ポイントということがもらえますでその m ポイントがどんなもの
かといいますと別のポイントにどんなに外部ポイントに交換することだっていきます
amazon の木スト県とかと交換できるかもしれませんねぇ
他にもですね動物カーバトルだけではなくいろんなカジュアルゲームにエムスポ機能が
追加されております
安来中身
設計バトル機能いいえ勝つとマジでポイントがもらえて
で別のポイントに交換できるんでマジで勝ちたくなりません
もないですよポイントが葬儀な
やるんじゃないでしょでこの ms パに対応しているゲーム抜いてこの3日間限定で
総額
婚約前500万円分の m ポイントの山芸イベントが開催されております
あの住宅たら毎週イベントがあるみたいなんですけどもぜひ500万円理由イベント
参加してみてはいかがでしょうか
通常の勝ち抜きバトルと違って賞品が豪華らしいですよぜひご参加ください
てどうスターがたら下の言われるからダメ元できます以前やってた人も
イオンもやってる人もまあ練ったことない人もぜひ web ポイントに入れるために
頑張ってみてはいかがでしょ
じゃーん
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ